wendy williams ex kevin hunter sues her
talk show for wrongful termination we've
got a lot to talk about on tuesday the
57 year old tv personality's ex-husband
filed a lawsuit against debmar mercury
the producer and distributor of the
wendy williams show according to court
documents obtained by e.t hunter claims
that debar mercury's decision to
terminate him was based on his marital
status e.t has reached out to hunter's
lawyer and debar mercury for comment
since getting divorced i'm getting used
to
life as a single woman again you know i
was married for over 25 years and now
i'm a woman of a particular age and a
particular station in life
so being single now is a lot different
i'm more mature i've got a lot at stake
more than i did back then i can be more
choosy
of course the two tied the knot in 1997.
i'm still in love he's over he's over
there and the daytime tv host filed for
divorce in april 2019. according to the
docs just days later hunter claims he
received written notice from debmar
mercury that he was fired as the
executive producer of the wendy williams
show and was no longer allowed on studio
premises
all is well
in hunterville
don't believe the hype hunter also
states that he was involved with the
daytime program since its inception in
2008 claiming that he was instrumental
to the show's success as he negotiated
produced and planned most of the
concepts and branding behind the show
the termination of plaintiff was based
strictly upon plaintiff's marital status
and his impending divorce to the show's
host ignoring all of the contributions
that plaintiff made to make the show a
success you know
marriages have ebbs and flows marriages
are not easy hunter who is demanding a
jury trial is seeking compensatory
punitive damages an award of costs
interests and attorney fees and more
amounting to no less than seven million
dollars per the docks adding that since
his firing he's been significantly
damaged reputationally professionally
and financially
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hunter's filing comes on the heels of
some major changes happening for the
wendy williams show last month debmar
mercury announced that the talker is
coming to an end following wendy's
season-long absence amid her ongoing
health struggles
so to all the tabloids and the blogs
that have been making up stories about
what's going on here you have heard it
directly from me the sheri show will
premiere this september sheri shepherd
will fill williams time slot with a new
talk show sherry which according to
deadline will include wendy's popular
hot topic segment
i'm ready to go let's get started it's
time for hot topic
and in the docs hunter claims that
segments he helped conceptualize will be
a part of shepherd's new show as for
wendy her rep recently told et that it's
been a challenging time but she is
incredibly grateful to debar mercury to
sherry and everybody else who has
supported the show through this time
you